one of the members of that legal team
rudy giuliani is being subpoenaed by
three House committees the former new
york mayor is mentioned more than thirty
times in a complaint drafted by the
intelligence community whistleblower
Giuliani denies any wrongdoing but has
admitted pushing Ukrainian officials to
investigate unsubstantiated claims of
wrongdoing by the Biden family Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy what a
Democrats hope to get with this subpoena
well Anthony Democrats note in the
subpoena that Giuliani himself has said
that he has evidence text messages phone
records that indicate that he got help
and encouragement from Trump
administration officials when he was
making these forays into Ukraine he said
last night he's still weighing whether
or not to testify
the sweeping subpoena from three House
Chairman gives Giuliani just two weeks
to produce over two and a half years
worth of documents on 23 related
subjects including his efforts to
pressure current or former Ukrainian
officials to investigate Joe Biden and
his son the letter to Giuliani cites
credible allegations that he acted as an
agent of the president in a scheme to
advance his personal political interests
by abusing the power of the office of
the president but I'll get all my
evidence together I'll get my charts I
don't know if they let me use videotapes
and tape recordings that I have
Democrats are moving quickly to set up
new interviews encouraged by new
national polls that indicate public
support for an impeachment inquiry is
growing and Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell said he would have no choice
but to take up an impeachment resolution
if it comes over from the house if the
house does go down that path and will
follow the Senate rules mr. Trump kept
up his attacks on The Whistleblower
Monday indicating he's searching for him
or her we're trying to find out about a
whistleblower when you have a
whistleblower that reports things that
were incorrect but that whistleblowers
complaint was corroborated by a call
summary released by the White House and
on Monday the intelligence community's
Inspector General also
released a three-page statement
debunking the president's claim noting
that the whistleblowers complaint was
found to be both urgent and credible you
think he's putting this whistleblowers
life at a risk I think this is a clear
example of reprisal Senate Intelligence
Committee vice-chair Mark Warner urged
mr. Trump to lay off the whistleblower I
think the potential threat to this
whistleblowers life is a realistic
concern kurt volker the former US
special envoy to ukraine who abruptly
resigned on friday is now set to testify
on thursday his associates confirm and
yesterday Democrats set deposition
request 2/3 of Giuliani's business
associates and if those associates
agreed to be deposed then that would
take place as early as next week Gail
all right Nancy thank you very much